when we think about modern engineering
and technology we tend instinctively to
think about sophisticated computing
devices and consumer electronics about
jet aircraft and bullet trains about
robots and lasers but in many ways the
products of modern engineering that have
the most substantial influence on our
lives are the ones we almost never think
about the everyday technologies that
surround us in our homes and workplaces
the infrastructure systems that have
been so beautifully integrated into the
fabric of modern civilization that
they're practically invisible and are
inevitably taken for granted consider a
typical day in your life your alarm
clock rings spring from your bed excited
to greet the new day glanced out the
window tells you that it snowed last
night
you're glad it's Saturday so you won't
have to venture out into the cold for a
few hours you walk to the bathroom flip
on a light and turn on the water to take
a shower and brush your teeth then head
for the kitchen to brew some coffee and
grab some fruit from the refrigerator a
friend calls he's on the road nap but he
invites you over to his place to watch
this afternoon's ballgame hop into your
car and drive across town to meet him
[Music]
it's just a typical day in a typical
week and yet in this simple series of
everyday activities you've made use of
an amazing array of technological
systems your homes structures supported
20 tons of accumulated snow on your roof
your heating system and insulation kept
your home at a comfortable temperature
50 degrees higher than that of the
outside air your plumbing system
supplied you with a stream of clean
water on demand and then carried the
waste water away from your shower sinks
and toilets into the municipal sewer
system which miraculously transformed
this stream of foul effluent into water
pure enough to return to a local stream
without harming the fish meanwhile a
vast regional electric power grid
supplied just the right amount of
electricity no more
needed for your lighting appliances and
hot water heater this power originated
in the chemical energy of coal that was
extracted from an underground mine
shipped by railroad and transformed into
electrical energy at a sprawling power
plant
many miles away from your home your
refrigerator provided precisely
controlled cooling which allowed you to
keep a generous supply of perishable
food on hand for immediate use that call
from your friend originated from his
moving vehicle and was transmitted
wirelessly from his mobile phone to a
cellular base station and then routed
seamlessly through the public telephone
network to your landline phone in your
drive across town you took advantage of
a wide array of automotive technologies
including the internal combustion engine
drivetrain suspension steering and
braking systems all working in concert
to keep your car moving and safely under
control your car burned gasoline that
originated in an underground reservoir
of raw petroleum which was tapped by a
drill rig pumped to the surface piped to
a refinery and processed into fuel you
navigated across town with the help of
the Global Positioning System a small
receiver in your car communicating with
a constellation of satellites far
overhead but you have never reached your
destination without an extensive system
of roads bridges tunnels and traffic
control technologies ranging from
automated signal lights to rail road
crossing gates at your friend's house
you watched a television broadcast
transmitted via a satellite orbiting
22,000 miles above the Earth's surface
and captured by the 18-inch dish antenna
mounted on his roof and so in just a few
hours of a typical day you used the
products of at least 12 different
engineering disciplines civil mechanical
electrical environmental transportation
chemical materials telecommunications
aerospace dust real mining and petroleum
engineering and this is what everyday
engineering is all about the purpose of
this course is to explore these everyday
technologies that contribute to our
quality of life in such a vital if
unappreciated at question has varied
somewhat through the ages but as it's
practiced today engineering is the
application of math science technology
and experience to create a system
component or process that serves our
society and let's spend a few minutes
parsing this definition so we can go
forward with a clear sense of what
engineering is and what it's not we'll
begin by looking at the unique
contributions of science math technology
and experience to the engineering
enterprise science provides us with
explanations about how the physical
world works sometimes these explanations
are true representations of nature but
often they aren't for example Newton's
laws of motion serve as a scientific
basis for the design of most of the
everyday technologies we'll be talking
about in this course even though we know
these laws aren't strictly correct
representations of how physical bodies
move in time and space from an
engineering perspective Newton's laws
are a lot simpler to apply than the
general theory of relativity and for
most practical applications their
predictive power is entirely sufficient
for their use in the design of
engineered systems deed from an
engineering perspective the only things
that really matter about a scientific
theory are its predictive power and its
ease of application a historical case in
point is the scientific theory of heat
now the first coherent theory describing
heat as a form of energy equivalent to
mechanical work was first published by
Sir Benjamin Thompson in 1798 by the
1850s the principle laws of
thermodynamics had been formulated and
were proving quite useful in the design
of steam engines yet as late as the
1880s scientists were still debating
what heat actually is with some claiming
incorrectly that it's a fluid which they
called caloric and others claiming
correctly that heat is actually the
motion of particles constituting matter
but even as the scientists debated the
engineers didn't care they had a
scientific theory that could predict the
power output of various steam engine
designs with reasonable accuracy and
that was all that mattered to engineers
the predictive power of a scientific
theory is so important because every
engineering design is at the most
fundamental level a prediction of the
future when an engineer designs a bridge
for example he or she is predicting that
the structural system will be capable of
safely carrying the maximum load the
bridge is likely to experience over its
entire lifetime and the basis for this
determination is a series of scientific
models used to predict internal forces
stresses deformations and material
strengths none of these predictions are
perfectly accurate but all are
sufficiently accurate to produce safe
designs all of these scientific models
are expressed mathematically because
physical phenomena are inherently
quantitative in nature the great natural
philosopher Galileo Galilei expressed
this idea elegantly when he wrote
philosophy by which he meant to science
philosophy is written in this grand book
the universe which stands continually
open to our gaze but the book cannot be
understood unless one first learns to
comprehend the language in which it is
written its
in the language of mathematics
mathematics is also the language of
engineering because technological
systems are envisioned designed
specified and constructed quantitatively
we need only look at this typical
engineering drawing to see that this is
true so what about technology well the
relationship between engineering and
technology is particularly fascinating
because technology is both a means to an
end and the end in itself the product of
engineering is technology yet technology
is also instrumental to the modern
engineering design process virtually all
modern engineering designs use
information technology because the
computational demands associated with
our modern scientific models can be met
far more efficiently by computers than
by stubby pencils and electronic
calculators but stubby pencils and
electronic calculators are technologies
too and they continue to perform an
important role in modern engineering as
do all sorts of other technologies like
materials testing equipment measuring
instruments and the machinery associated
with manufacturing and construction
these tools of the engineering process
are themselves all products of
engineering by the way this same
circular relationship also exists
between science and technology science
contributes immeasurably to the design
of modern technology and yet modern
science would be impossible without
technological tools like electron
microscopes satellites and particle
accelerators its value notwithstanding
the role of science and engineering is
sometimes overstated after all many of
humankind's most important inventions
and technological innovations have been
created with little or no scientific
basis at best the people who built the
very first wheeled vehicles water power
aqueducts and cathedrals could only draw
upon a qualitative understanding of the
physical world the invention
the steam engine proceeded and actually
inspired the science of thermodynamics
conversely the role of experience in
engineering is often underappreciated
consider the modern automobile the
invention of which is generally
attributed to Karl Benz in 1886 the year
since then the sciences of mechanics
thermodynamics chemistry and electricity
have contributed mightily to the
development of this machine but much of
its long-term development must also be
attributed to experience careful
observation empirical testing trial and
error and meticulous refinement
interspersed with occasional bursts of
creative insight this site of
engineering has little to do with
science and everything to do with
ingenuity the modern engineering
Enterprise is broad and highly diverse
recall that my simple example at the
start of this lecture touched upon
twelve different engineering disciplines
each of these disciplines has its own
extensive body of knowledge and its own
problem-solving approaches as such the
scope of this course on everyday
engineering could be impossibly broad
I've attempted to address this challenge
with a simple organizing construct in
this course will restrict our
exploration of everyday engineering to
the major technological systems you're
likely to encounter in and around your
home and during a short drive across
town we'll begin by focusing on the
house itself we'll look at the typical
American single-family residence as an
engineered system consisting of eight
distinct but interrelated subsystems
structure foundation building envelope
sight plumbing electrical heating and
cooling and telecommunications now
several of these subsystems are
integrally connected to vast
infrastructure networks your plumbing to
a municipal water supply and sewage
system your electrical system to a
regional power grid your phone to the
public telephone network and we'll
explore these large-scale engineered
systems as well
within the home we'll examine a few
representative examples of the thousands
of simple machines and gadgets you
encounter every day we'll take a look at
the principle technological systems used
in your automobile and then we'll hit
the road for an overview of roads
bridges tunnels and transportation
engineering and then finally we'll wrap
up with a look at the technological
challenge of solid waste disposal as a
lead-in to an overview of the brave new
world of sustainable engineering design
and some reflections on its implications
for our everyday lives
arthur c clarke the renowned science
fiction writer and futurist once wrote
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic but I
disagree no doubt technology can
sometimes seem both mysterious and
intimidating but we can all understand
it we can distinguish it from magic if
we just devote ourselves to the task for
each of the technologies we'll explore
in these lectures we'll attempt to
answer three big questions first and
foremost how does it work
second what are the key scientific
principles on which its design and
operation are based third because no
technology's perfect how and why does it
sometimes fail now in defining the scope
of this course I'll add three important
caveats first this is not a history
course so we generally won't explore the
historical development of the
technologies we address I have found
however that historical development can
sometimes be a very powerful tool for
enhancing understanding of technology
and in such cases I've happily included
it for example the fourth-generation
cellular telephone of today is almost
indistinguishable from magic
on the other hand the simple first
generation phone of 1983 or so is
actually quite understandable thus if we
start with the 1g phone and then examine
the three successive incremental
improvements
2g 3g and 4g will ultimately be much
better equipped to appreciate the
current state-of-the-art second caveat
some aspects of everyday engineering the
us are quite different from everyday
engineering elsewhere this is
particularly true for residential
construction and electrical power where
these differences exist I'll do my best
to call attention to them but for the
sake of time our focus must necessarily
be on the US version of these
technologies and third this course will
not address computers or home
electronics clearly these technologies
are both important and prevalent in our
everyday lives however I am unable to
address them in this course in part
because they're just too far beyond my
own expertise but also because they're
sufficiently distinct from the topics
that I will be addressing that they
truly require courses of their own
fortunately the great courses does offer
a superb lecture series called
understanding modern electronics by
Professor rich Wolfson if you're
interested in the subject I do hope
you'll check it out so why is everyday
engineering a subject worth studying
even if you are not an engineer well I'd
like to offer three reasons first we can
all benefit from being informed users of
technology when you're shopping for a
new car and looking at a set of engine
specifications like this one it would be
helpful to know what these terms
displacement horsepower torque and
compression ratio actually mean to know
the difference between a dual overhead
camshaft and a single overhead camshaft
and the difference between direct and
multi-port fuel injection when you're
building contractor tells you that he's
going to insulate your walls that are 19
you really ought to know what in our
value is and whether the potential
energy savings might justify paying for
more than our 19 when your plumbing
system breaks you'll benefit from
understanding what went wrong even if
your plumber will be doing the repair if
nothing else you're really ought to know
that just inside one of your wall
there's a valve like this one which can
be used to shut off the water supply to
your entire house knowing where this
valve is located is a reasonably good
alternative to the thousands of dollars
in water damage that could happen
between the time when you first noticed
the leak and the time when the plumber
actually arrives second knowing
something about everyday engineering can
make us better citizens you know on the
day I started working on this Lacher
this issue of my local newspaper arrived
at my doorstep and quite appropriately
all three of the main front page stories
were directly related to topics covered
in this course on this day in
Pennsylvania the state's Public Utility
Commission implemented a new regulation
that drastically improved individual
consumers ability to switch from one
electric power supplier to another the
regional utility companies vigorously
opposed this plan on this day the state
Department of Transportation announced
the approval of a two hundred and fifty
million dollar project to widen a major
highway that suffers from serious
overcrowding but because the project is
being funded with gas taxes and higher
tolls it was opposed by many local
politicians and on this day several
municipalities initiated a case with a
state Superior Court challenging the
constitutionality of the state's oil and
gas law on the grounds that many
incidents involving shale gas wells
polluting local water supplies weren't
being publicly reported by the state's
environmental regulators these are
challenging issues with complex economic
social political and environmental
implications and as an engaged citizen I
should take well reasoned positions on
issues like deregulation of the power
industry public investment in
transportation infrastructure and
environmental impact of shale gas
exploration and I should consider these
issues when I vote for the officials who
influence these policies but can i
really take a well-reasoned position on
any of these issues without some
understand
The Associated technologies for example
can I reasonably oppose fracking I don't
even know what fracking is third and
perhaps most important everyday
engineering is worth studying because
it's just immensely rewarding and just
played fun to learn about the world
around us there's nothing new in this of
course many people myself included find
great satisfaction in identifying stars
in the night sky in distinguishing a
red-tailed hawk from a turkey vulture an
oak tree from a red maple a piece of
granite from a lump of quartz but I've
always been just a little disappointed
that most people don't seem to have the
same enthusiasm for the technological
world as they have for the natural world
the technological world is certainly no
less interesting perhaps the problem is
just that we technology enthusiasts
don't have the same sorts of information
resources that are so readily available
to stargazers and bird watchers I hope
this course will provide just such a
resource by serving as a sort of field
guide to everyday technology today if
you notice this utility pole at all you
probably see little more than a tangle
of wires but by the end of this course
you'll be able to discern three
high-voltage power distribution feeders
three insulators a neutral wire a
transformer a fuse a low voltage
distribution line a telephone cable a
fiber optic line and a structural guy
wire you'll also be able to distinguish
a highway clover leaf from a flyover
interchange you'll recognize this
structure as a water supply tower and
this one as a sewage clarification tank
and I hope you'll take great
satisfaction in doing so simply because
these various species of everyday
technology are integral components of
the built environment in which we live
work and play now as we explore the
world of everyday technology over the
next 35 lectures we're going to
encounter some recurring themes I'd like
to conclude today's lecture by
raising your awareness of these four
threads of continuity so perhaps they'll
be more meaningful when we encounter
them again later in the course first
theme there is no such thing as an ideal
technology engineering always involves
trade-offs to achieve an optimum
solution with respect to one criterion
we must inevitably compromise on one or
more other criteria for example as a
fuel for generating electrical power
coal is cheap plentiful and particularly
well suited for generating large steady
power output 24 hours a day but coal is
also the most environmentally
detrimental energy source in our current
portfolio on the other hand renewable
energy sources like wind and solar are
far more environmentally friendly but
they have the significant disadvantage
of only producing power sporadically
when the wind is blowing and the sun is
shining and because we currently have no
technological capability for large-scale
power storage renewables aren't
currently capable of meeting our total
energy demands we'll encounter these
sorts of engineering trade-offs in every
single lecture of this course second
theme a collective love-hate
relationship with technology we love the
conveniences afforded by abundant
electrical power but refuse to buy a
home anywhere near a high voltage
transmission line we support increased
generation of renewable energy as long
as those offshore wind turbines are
built along somebody else's favorite
stretch of coastline we're addicted to
our cell phones but will vigorously
protest the construction of a new cell
tower in our neighborhood in this course
I hope we can reconcile these sorts of
contradictory positions just a bit I
know I can't convince you to like that
ugly cell tower but I can't explain why
it needs to be right there why it must
be tall and why it doesn't necessarily
have to be quite so ugly third theme
the substantial role of government in
everyday engineering throughout this
course we'll see the impacts of
government regulation in implementing
the building codes that govern the
design and construction of our homes the
engineering standards for highway design
water quality and energy efficiency and
even the operation of that traffic light
at the end of your street we'll also see
how deregulation has reshaped the US
electric power telephone and railroad
industries and has significantly
influenced the services we receive from
these industries
we'll see how government incentive
programs have been used to spur
technological development sometimes for
better sometimes for worse so is
government involvement in everyday
engineering a good thing or a bad thing
well if you answer this question from an
ideological perspective there's a clear
yes or no depending on your political
orientation but if you answer it from an
engineering perspective the answer must
be far more nuanced as you'll see the
impact of government involvement depends
on the specific government action on the
context on the interface with relevant
professional communities especially on
the technology itself final theme and by
far the most important in developing
this course I've been struck again and
again with a sense of wonder at the
remarkable human achievements reflected
in these seemingly mundane works of
everyday Engineering our beautifully
integrated systems for residential
construction water purification
electrical power distribution
telecommunications and transportation
are triumphs of human imagination
ingenuity and persistence that
substantially improve the quality of
life for millions of people they may not
be indistinguishable from magic
as Arthur Clarke suggested but they are
magical as you experience these human
achievements in the lectures ahead I
hope you'll gain a keener appreciation
for the works of the countless engineers
who've done so much good work largely
behind the scenes to make our lives
better they are in many ways the unsung
heroes of our technology intensive world
indeed I can think of no better way to
reinforce this point and to conclude
this lecture than to recite an excerpt
from Rudyard Kipling's wonderful poem
the sons of Martha this title is an
allusion to the New Testament story of
Mary and Martha two sisters who were
visited by Jesus and responded in very
different ways
during the visit Mary sat at the Lord's
feet listening to his words and enjoying
his company while Martha was preoccupied
with the household chores
the poem is Kipling's tribute to the
engineers of his day whom he
characterizes as the sons of Martha
here's the excerpt they do not preach
that their God will rouse them a little
before the nuts work loose they do not
teach that his pity allows them to drop
their job when they damn well choose as
in the thronged and lighted ways so in
the dark and desert they stand wary and
watchful all their days that their
Brethren's days may be long in the land
raisi the stone or cleave the wood to
make a path more fair or flat low it's
black already with blood some son of
Martha spilled for that not as a ladder
from earth to heaven not as a witness to
any Creed but simple service simply
given to his own kind in their common
need as it was in Kipling's day so is
the work of the engineer today simple
serve is simply given yet also heroic in
a quiet unobtrusive way next lecture
we'll learn how the simple service of
the engineer is manifested in the design
of your house